resuelve para x 9 x cuadrada menos 42 x
29 igual a menos 20 y aquí lo primero
que quiero que te des cuenta antes de
locarno si factorizar el lado izquierdo
de forma compulsiva lo primero que me
gustaría que te dieras cuenta es que
esta no es una ecuación que está
igualada a cero con tantos y nosotros
factor izamos el lado izquierdo
tendremos dos binomios que igualados me
dan menos 20 y eso no nos ayudaría mucho
que digamos de hecho siempre que
tengamos una ecuación cuadrática lo
mejor para resolverla es igualar la cero
por lo tanto lo primero que voy a hacer
antes de resolver la factorización del
lado izquierdo de esta ecuación es
igualar la cero y para igualar la cero
lo que tengo que hacer es sumar de ambos
lados de la ecuación 20 por lo tanto va
a ser más 20 más 20 o dicho de otra
manera estoy pasando al menos 20 del
otro lado de la ecuación y entonces
ahora si me va a quedar 9 x cuadrada 9 x
cuadrada menos 42 x hasta aquí no hay
ningún problema y después de 29 20 lo
cual me da 49 y del otro lado tengo
menos
20 que es 0 y date cuenta que ahora sí
ya tenemos una ecuación cuadrática la
cual está igualada 0 y eso es muy
importante porque entonces ahora sí
podemos resolverla y voy a intentar
resolverla por factorización otra vez
pero antes de buscar dos números que los
sumados me den menos 42 y multiplicados
media en 49 quiero que te des cuenta que
tanto 9 x cuadrada como 49 tienen raíz
cuadrada exacta por lo tanto lo que se
me ocurre es sacar sus raíces cuadradas
y ver si de pura casualidad es un
binomio cuadrado perfecto la raíz de 9 x
cuadrada es 3x es decir 9 x cuadrada es
lo mismo que 3x elevado al cuadrado y la
raíz de 49 7 por lo tanto 7 elevado al
cuadrado 49 y vamos a ver si de pura
casualidad aquí en medio está dos veces
el primero por el segundo 2 por 13 6 por
7 es 42 perfecto lo único que me hace
falta es un signo si yo le pongo aquí
menos 72 por 13 6 por menos 7 me da
menos 42 es decir que aquí en medio
tengo dos veces el primero por el
segundo lo que significa que si es 1
cuadrado perfecto fíjate bien aquí tengo
dos por tres por menos 7 2 por 3 6 por 7
42 negativo y entonces ya tengo dos
veces del primero por el segundo lo cual
me hace pensar que esto lo puedo
escribir como un binomio cuadrado
perfecto esto es lo mismo que 3x menos
siete elevado al cuadrado 3x menos 7
elevado al cuadrado esto va a ser igual
a cero es lo que tenemos ahora de esta
ecuación y tenemos 3x menos 7 por 3 x
menos 7 igual a 0 o dicho de otra manera
tenemos un binomio elevado al cuadrado
igualado a cero y por lo tanto pues
solamente la parte de adentro tiene que
ser igual a cero 3x menos 7 es igual a 0
y de aquí ya podemos despejar a equis
sumamos 7 de ambos lados me queda 3x del
lado izquierdo y del lado derecho me
queda 7 positivo es decir 3 x igual a 7
y después voy a dividir todo entre 3
está entre 3 es entre 3 y me queda que x
es igual a 7 tercios la solución de esta
ecuación de segundo grado es x igual a 7
tercios ya hemos acabado dándonos cuenta
de que este entreno me el cuadrado
perfecto y además de que pasamos el
menos 20 del otro